-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
yesterday unveiled
a new postage stamp
that honors former
First Lady Nancy Reagan.
The stamp will be very helpful
when you need to figure out
which birthday card
came from your grandparents.
"Let's see.
Flower, flower, Snoopy,
gay pride, oh!
Here we go."
Transportation Secretary
Pete Buttigieg
announced yesterday that
he has tested positive
for a breakthrough case
of the coronavirus.
Unfortunately, he's still not
old enough for the vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
According to reports, former
President Trump's advisors
are divided on if Trump should
announce his re-election
campaign
before this year's
midterm elections or wait
so he does not take attention
away from other candidates.
Oh, 'cause he'd hate
stealing attention.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's like a bridesmaid who
keeps mentioning in her speech
that it's her half-birthday.
[ Laughter ]
According to reports,
former President Trump
may launch his re-election
campaign on July 4th,
so step aside, dogs!
It's our turn to hate that day!
[ Laughter ]
That's a good --
That's a very good
"scared of a fireworks" dog,
right there.
[ Laughter ]
That's how you say it,
"a fireworks," right?
Yeah, yeah.
'Cause it sounded weird,
but that's definitely
the way you say it.
The sixth installment of
the dinosaur sci fi series
called
"Jurassic World: Dominion"
will be released this Friday
in theaters.
Man, if that series goes on
any longer,
they're gonna have to
include mammals.
[ Laughter ]
"The horses are out!"
Lawmakers in New York
recently passed
the so-called
Stop the Chop Act,
which will allow residents
to sue companies
for excessive helicopter noise.
So now, New York residents
will only have to deal with
noise from garbage trucks,
street sweepers,
ambulances, weed whackers,
leaf blowers,
and people screaming when a rat
pops its head out of a bodega.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a guinea pig
in Hungary named Molly
was recently honored with the
Guinness World Record
for most basketball slam dunks
in 30 seconds.
But before you get too excited,
full disclosure,
apparently the rim was only set
at 9 feet, 6 inches.
[ Light laughter ]
You know,
I was a little concerned
that that was our closer.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But you know what,
then I thought,
trust the process.
Baze knows.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know why.
You know what, guys? Look.
The important thing is,
we told that joke.
[ Laughter ]
We had the courage to tell it.
That was a monologue, everybody!
We have a fantastic
show for you tonight.